hi everyone it's Jerry I have a smooth
game to share with you from the 2007
Linares tournament on the wide end 16
year old Magnus Carlson and he's playing
against Vasily vonchuk
okay I think that this is an excellent
model game against the grunfeld
we have an exchange grenfeld and the
focus for these next few moves are going
to be on
all right is going to be on the D4
Square
I'm actually going to put pressure there
and White's going to arrange his pieces
so that he can support it adequately
so here we go with the fine Keto
not a bad diagonal for the light Square
Bishop pointing at the weakest Square F7
you wouldn't want to go to D3 you're not
as active and you're also in the way
Queen can't see D4 directly
okay there's a reason the bishop is out
and about this early it's because the
king Knight wants to be on E2 with this
setup
now you certainly wouldn't want to be on
E2 if the bishop is still on home base
white would experience a coordination
issue
now why is the Knight going to E2 rather
than his favorite Square F3
is because at some point black can pin
the Knight
I emphasize at some point because
playing it right now is tactically
flawed Bishop takes F7 Knight G5 check
and there goes the bishop
but certainly with some prep work by
black like castles once The Rook is
there securing F7 this idea to pin the
Knight and eliminate a key defender of
D4 is there
what's the difference with the Knight I
need to well any Bishop G4 can now be
met with F3 and the pin is broken
so in short
we can say the Knight on E2 is not as
actively posted but a reliable defender
of D4
all right Queen side miners play a role
attack and defense of D4 both sides
Castle
black goes after the bishop no way
B6
okay the reply here is Rook C1
trying to win a pawn like this is not
really recommended because black would
have excellent play on The Queen side
there is one square that sticks out to
me here it's the Knight getting to C4
and also the queen positions in this
position this is a very stable Square
for the black queen and
I'm not sure where the comfortable
Square for the White Queen would really
be within this environment within this
structure
in any case white of course recognizes
the strength in this ideal Pawn Center
so he keeps it
and gets The Rook off of the main
diagonal
now the reply here by black is to
exchange on D4 we're exchanging C pawns
this Rook
can now see the world
the computer has a bit of an issue with
this it's a slight one but this is one
of those games where there's this
gradual Improvement for white and this
is maybe the very beginning of this
gradual Improvement I want to draw some
attention to this important middle game
position
what does the computer want to play here
it says
increase the pressure on D4 don't be so
quick to justify White's last move don't
be so quick to open up the C file
now this move E5 before you can play
that move
there's a lot you must Digest
the structure can change in a few
different ways do you have a good sense
of each of these structures we're going
to have a look at three of them both
captures and then the push
the captures are considered equal
the push not so much it likes black in
fact
let's first look at what's considered
the equalish continuations this one
right here
white still works with the pawn Duo all
right it's just shifted to the right a
little bit no D4 in E4 but instead E4 F4
that's one way another is to capture on
C5
and play this down upon as black but
again black has play on The Queen side
The Rook is looking good
the Knight getting into C4 is looking
good
and also this Knight on E2 black kind of
points his finger at that piece within
this structure and says you're
ridiculous
it's a very poorly positioned Knight
can have Fallout moves Queen B8 Rook C8
very active play for the black pieces on
the queen side
finally
the reply
in reply to E5 D5 very very tempting
move but bad
very tempting because normally this is
great
I have now a connected past Pawn why is
that not good well check this line out
as an example
F5 F3 F4 with tempo
C4 with Tempo I know I'm making a lot of
moves but here we are within this very
fixed
structure who stands better
well
Lighthouse space here Pawn in the center
but black has space here and here but
let's just focus in this structure on
these two Pawns
it's very difficult for white to
coordinate with this guy right here it's
easily blockaded
black can interact with this guy he
could coordinate with the F Pawn black
has this idea to play
G5 G4 this is a position you will see
it's very similar I should say too a
king's Indian defense Mardel Plata but
the big difference here is that it is
locked up on the queen side this is
normally the side of the board where
white will be looking to play in the
king's Indie defense but now it's
completely bottled up on the queen side
and what do you do what would White's
active plan be here he kind of just has
to sit and wait there's no great way to
interact with this guy here so this is
not a good structure for white to get
himself into
look at this poor Knight again doesn't
even have a square here
in any case E5 is the suggestion here a
lot you have to again digest before
making that move
in this game the C file is opened up
black goes with E6 you may think about
well let's just go ahead and feed keto
right away but if you're doing that
there's D5 and now if you try to
challenge you're saying I'm okay taking
out an isolated E Pawn
so it is first
E6 fending off
the D5 advance
Queen D2 forming a battery connecting
Rooks
Black's now ready to put the bishop on
B7
from here H form this
is my favorite move of the game
it's a poison Pawn
that's not why it's my favorite move of
the game it's my favorite move of the
game because I think many
players well I think what's tempting let
me say it like this I think what's
tempting is to say to yourself hey what
piece isn't playing hey where is there
an open file hey let's double on the C
file let's form a battery batteries are
great right you really end up just
going nowhere we end up just exchanging
Rooks if you focus on
forming a battery on the C file what is
white looking to do by playing H4 he's
looking to establish a thorn in Black's
side he's looking to have this Pawn be a
disruptor to Black's King side H5 are
you gonna play H6 are you gonna capture
on G6
it's difficult for black to answer these
questions or have a reply to these moves
you'll note the king Knight right with
this grinfeld defense what Knights are
exchanged very early on the blacks King
Knight and White's Queen Knight
if there's no
King Knight around when there's this
feeling cut out on the king side
when this guy is on G6 this idea to rush
the pawn up to H5 is that much more
appealing because
King Knight is not around to watch over
this advance so this is a nice way to
try and break down Black's kingside and
create some weaknesses
this guy is poison
the reply here is Queen E7 if the pawn
is picked up the queen is trapped
she be trapped Bishop G5 and where are
you going you got two options let's have
a look at this one first
Queen H5 met with Knight G3
and Bishop E2 she's a goner
one other variation is after Bishop G5
suppose the queen goes here first well
we give her a kick with F3
and then Knight G3 she's a goner again
so the H pun
poison
in the game Queen E7
H5
Rook F to C8
E5 so with E5
there's now a focus on a couple squares
one
F6
well it has control over this hole with
a pawn and also G6 The Bishop's eyes are
now opened to that square there's a big
difference here between the light Square
Bishops they're not competing for the
same diagonal each is trying to
demonstrate hey my Bishop is better than
yours well white is really
the one who's saying or White's Bishop
is the better Bishop
okay it's different if this queen is
somehow able to coordinate on G2 but
that's not happening
in the game we got a pair of Rooks off
in fact two Rooks are coming off and
white is okay initiating The Exchange
here because that force is black too
under develop
from here Bishop G5 sneaking in on the
dark squares is the play at this stage
the strategy
the reply Queen C7 what is regarded as
best
Queen D7 with the idea to at least
try and win that D4 Pawn but it's still
going to be a very difficult road ahead
Queen C7 in this game it seems very
logical it is an open file but if we
consider the entry points for the queen
look at these guys here
they're just saying no way I got all
those squares covered because of these
two minor pieces
so this queen could feel a bit more
comfortable going in on the attack here
towards the king
all right Bishop F6
and the reply here is Knight C6 so
if black is exchanging I want to have a
look at the exchange in the retreat if
you exchange Bishops now you have to
deal with this Pawn you have to you have
to deal with the queen H6 Queen G7
and what do you do to stop that the
queen would have to put pressure on F6
or at least be in a position to go to f8
Queen G5 is very strong and now there
are these these ideas is a sacrifice on
G7 this is getting broken down and even
if it's defended Leica put his full
weight on G6 and there's going to be an
accident happening on that square very
soon while this Knight watches from the
side
okay not a good idea to take the bishop
nor is it really a good idea to retreat
like this because again right around the
corner there is this accident that's
going to happen on G6
I'll just show one sample line let's say
this Knight gets back in business there
we go with the check on G6
we can get these captures in and there
you go the queen is winning the Knight
next light is up two pawns completely
winning here
so these tricks are there on the G6
Square black plays it with Knight C6
and now there's only one well Far and
Away there is one clearly winning move
and Carlson finds it
very easy to go wrong here
he plays Queen G5 now
if you try the exchange first and then
H6 this seems appealing on the surface I
must say but after King f8 you're trying
to sneak in here right but it's poorly
timed
because the queen could play here and
you're not getting to that F6 square if
you're able to get to F6 then you're
going to be able to get here and then
track the pawn down you'd have a passer
but black is there in time to stop that
maneuver so that's why white in this
position is first starting with Queen G5
now the idea is
let's say black played Bishop to B7 here
now the idea is to take
then give the check and our Queen is in
this position already
ready to get to F6 and next
h8 when the pawn push this guy through
and win
what does black try here to interfere
with the idea to take the bishop and
then plant the pawn here followed up
with Queen F6
he says go away he plays H6
now for
these past few moves the focus here has
been on the king side
focused on the F6 Square the G6 Square
the pawn getting to H6 all these King
side squares check out this next Smooth
Move
and that is
Queen coming all the way back to C1
white immediately now reminds black
of a pin
this is excellent board Vision we have
two things going on now
this
Point here on the king side G6 is
hanging two attackers
one Defender
and black also has to sort out this pin
this is two problems too many
what does black try here while he
addresses the threat on G6 by playing G5
and now white is able to take full
advantage over this pinned Knight
Pop Quiz here which move would you play
with the bishop would you go to B5 to
attack the Knight or E4
feel free to pause the video
okay
the better choice
the winning move with the bishop is B5
y B5 we're going to see in just a little
bit
first things first though black must
defend the Knight you can't move the
Knight
drop the queen so Bishop D7 is the
follow-up and now in comes
D5
beautiful move this is attacking the
pinned Knight and also clearing the way
for Knight D4
let's pause for a moment this position
right here
how did we get here
where 25 moves in we have white has
established two Bishops in Black's house
and three Pawns
I think it dates all the way back to
this idea right here advancing that H
Pawn it was a very very disruptive idea
beautiful position to take note of
there's not a single piece in White's
house but all of these white pieces in
Black's house
D4 is now opened up for the night
black continues with the capture on D5
and follow up here is Knight D4
and the pin on the Knight White's gonna
soon win some material what is the
difference
if you went to E4 instead of B5 well you
know in this very position if the bishop
was on e4
white would have to react to this threat
on the bishop
because the bishop is on B5 light gets
to play this Advance after the recapture
there's no threat on the bishop here and
white gets to follow up with Knight D4
this guy is toast
we have the exchange of dark Square
Bishops black gets out of the PIN
but it's too late White's able to win
the minor piece and what do we have two
black pawns versus a light Square Bishop
some time is now taken out to safeguard
the king to give him a new Square
Queen C5 now if it's a balanced
position material wise you may you wanna
you may want to think twice about this
decision but
uh uh White is okay exchanging Queens
here and giving black connected past
pawns because they're not going to go
anywhere
the plan here punch a hole in the light
squares
so he puts how do you do that you put a
little pressure on a pawn that's on a
light Square
that guy away once that pawn moves there
you go there's the hole
Bishop B5 is there really a better
diagonal for the bishop you're watching
over
both Pawn advances they're going nowhere
so now that they are restricted this is
where white connects improve the king
he kicks off first with F4
controlling a dark Square the bishop
could always control this Square
the idea here bring the king up to the
center end eventually Black's going to
run out of moves White's going to win
some more material
this game ends though after the exchange
on F4
G takes F4 black simply resigns
uh he trusts the 16 year old's technique
here in this end game
uh what do you even try if we play out
some moves here how might the game
continue we bring the Kings towards the
center
white would say no way I'm not letting
you get here let's say that pawn is
saved
how you stopping the the king from
getting to E4
if the king gets here he's gonna get
here and eventually you run out of moves
and this Pawn is going to fall
if you try to stop the king from
entering this is how white can approach
it
the King has to stay close
to defending this Pawn at any moment it
could be targeted so
something like this
we can have
where
the king puts pressure here
and the bishop puts pressure here and
this guy cannot defend both white will
soon
win upon
and it should be very easy to convert it
from that point on
but this one goes no further after the
simple recapture on F4
black resigns
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
foreign